みなさんこんにちは
今先ほどご紹介にあずかりました
今年青学を卒業しました今のと巻と申します
今日はですねまあこのようなキャリアは自分の価値観探しというようなテーマで皆さん
にお話ができればなというふうに思っていますよろしくお願い致します
まず最初に簡単に僕自身の自己紹介をさせて頂ければと思うんですけれども
僕はもともと宮城県仙台市出身です
18歳の頃に状況をしまして今はえーっ
先ほど紹介があっておりですね今年青学を卒業して
任官のモチベーショングループという会社でキャリアナビゲーターよという仕事をして
います
大学時代これから僕自身の経験というものもお話しさせていただくんですけれども
例えば学生団体の活動に打ち込んでいたりですとか
長期インターンを複数社経験したりま npo をつくってみたり
あとはメディアの方にも様々出演させていただいたりと本当にたくさんの経験をさせて
いただいてきます
たん
今日はそういった自分自身の経験だったりそこからどのようなことを考えて今の
キャリアを選択したのか皆さんにお伝えできればというふうに思っています
では早速ですが皆さんにひとつお聞きしたいことがあります
皆さんはですね自分のキャリアというものをどのように選択しているでしょうか
まず最初に何ですが私自身のキャリアというものについてご説明をさせていただきたい
と思います
僕自身はですねもう0歳の頃からずっと水泳をやっておりまして
18歳の高校卒業までもひたすら水泳ばかりの生活をしていました
を0歳と言うと本当にベビースイミングで後水にプカプカ浮かべられるようなところ
からですね
まあ曲がりなりにも高校卒業までずっと競技に打ち込んできました
戦績もそれなりに良くてですね県大会で優勝したりですとか
全国大会に出場したりあとは高校進学の際にですね
強豪校からオファーをいただいたりということで自分なりに成績を残すことができてい
ました
で高校自体は自分自身勉強も水泳も両方頑張りたいなというふうに思っていたのでそれ
ができるような環境を自分自身で選択して
日々取り組んでいました
しかしですね高校2年生の冬でした僕自身
神経質な性格もあり病気になってしまいます
当時のことを振り返るとやはり選手として成果が出ていた頃だったので非常に悩みまし
た
どういう選択をしようかと自分自身いろいろ考えていたんですがそこで取った選択と
いうのがここに書いてある
マネージャーという選択です
水泳というスポーツ皆さんもご存知かなというふうに思うんですが
究極の個人スポーツだというふうに思っています
自分自身の成績やタイムこれが良ければもうそれが自分自身の結果として皆さんに評価
をされます
そういった環境ではなかなか誰かのために頑張るみたいな視点を持つことが少なかった
んですね
ただ結果としてマネージャーとなりー自分じゃない
他の選手たちのサポートをするという立場に回った瞬間に結果としてこれが
自分にすごく適性を感じることができたんです
選手の時には感じられなかった自分は誰かのためにがんばるとか誰かのサポートをする
こういったところに適性があるのかなというふうに思いそのまま最後の1年間は
マネージャーとして
選手をサポートする役割を
やりました
で本当に今思うとま辛い経験だったなというふうに思うんですけれども負けがの興行と
言いますか
今振り返ると自分自身がキャリアを方向付けてくれた大きな出来事だったなというふう
に思っています
そこから大学に進学しました
皆さんご存知の方もいるかもしれませんがや小山学院大学ボランティアステーションと
いうボランティアの企画運営をする団体に入りました
今はルートというふうに今名前が変わっているんですけれどもこういった団体に僕は
所属をしました
でこれも縁なのか僕自身高校2年生の頃にですね
この団体のことを地元仙台の進軍で実は目にしたことがあったんです
こういったご縁から自分自身高校のマネージャーの経験もあって本当に誰かのために
頑張りたいとか
自分自身の時間というのを必要とされている人たちに使っていきたいなというふうに
思いこの団体に息をすることができました
少しだけこの団体の説明をさせていただきますと左のほうに企画のサイクルの頭が書い
ているんですけれども
まず企画の作成企画書の t 室から
現地の関係者とも連絡を取ったりですとか
予算をつくったりあとは実際のプロプログラムの正
ね地面とはもちろんですが活動は終わった後の報告会の実施
こういった一連のサイクルを学生自らが主体となり作り上げていく
そんな団体です
今活動を振り返ると僕自身は東北の支援をする部署にへ
エントリーをして入ったんですけれどもそれ以外にも例えば大学周辺地域
今で言うと渋谷区の清掃活動であったり
福祉施設でのボランティアあとは発展途上国ですねインドネシアとかネパールとか
フィリピンとか
そういった活動をしている部分もあったんですけれどもやはり北自身があの3.11の
震災を守ろに経験したという立場から伝えられることがあるかなというふうに思い
東北の支援をする一緒に乳房しましょう
この団体に入って幸いなことに僕自身は高校1年生の後半から
プロジェクトリーダーというところに推薦をいただきましてそこからもう23年ぐらい
ずっと
この活動に従事してきたわけなんですけれども
ここでですねまた僕のキャリアを決定づけてくれる大きな出来事にであります
糸僕が大学2年生の夏でした
当時教育学科1年生の女の子がですねプロジェクトに参加してくれました
その子は自分自身が将来小学校の先生になるか
中学校の先生になるか非常に迷っていたという風に言っていたんですけれども
今回このプロジェクトに参加をして中学生に燕京教える活動に参加してくれました
その経験を生かして私は将来中学校の先生になることを決めました
こんな言葉を僕にくれたんですね
非常に何でしょ今振り返っても1年間の規格っていう中で大変なことだったり辛いこと
をたくさんあったんですけれども
その一言がものすごく嬉しくてある改めて僕自身は誰かのキャリアだったりとか
人生そういったものを方向付ける手助けをしたいんだなというふうに気づくことができ
ました
またもう一つエビソードがございましてこれも当時
教育学科の一個上の先輩だったんですけれども
観光促進いわゆる宮城県に観光客をもっと予防
そういうプロジェクトに参加してくれた方がいました
その方は当時はあまり東北だったりとか
地方というところに興味がなかったみたいなんですけれども活動に参加をすることで
もっともっとこういった分野を勉強していきたいということで実際にまあ大学院に進学
をされ高校でチリを教えながら緊急を進めているそんな方もいらっしゃいます
ああああああ
こういった大学での自分自身の実体験も踏まえて改めて
僕自身が将来やりたいことキャリアの選択が明確になったかなというふうに思ってい
ます
はいということでここまでですねまぁ僕自身の経験をお話しさせていただきました
いくどとなくキャリアという言葉を使わせていただいたんですけれども皆さんはこの
キャリアという言葉についてどのようなイメージを持たれているでしょうか
はいえーとこのキャリアという言葉なんですけれども語源を遡ると
轍という言葉が元になっています
はたちというのは車が道路を走った後につく
タイヤの跡のことを言っています
つまり巷ではよくキャリアというと自分の将来について語られることが多いんですが
元を辿れば自分の過去ですねこれまで描いてきた過去について差している言葉というの
がおわかりいただけるかなと思います
そういった意味でもここまでは僕自身の過去の経験についてお話をさせていただきます
はいそしてですね僕自身が今のキャリアを選択するにあたって
もう一つ重要視したことがございますそれが今の世の中の流れです
こういったスライドを準備させていただきました
価値の主体ということで戦後復興期は業界が勝ちの主体でした
そこから高度経済成長期に鍋につれて企業が価値を持つと
今はさらに経済の it 化だったりとかソフトかというものが進んでおりますので
個人が価値を持つ
そういった時代に入ってきています
また ai の導入だったりとかま巷で話題になっていると思いますがこれを導入さ
れることで今後
選ばれる個人と選ばれない個人というのが二極化してくるという風に私は考えています
そのようなまあ世の中の流れの中で僕自身の一つキーワードとして挙げているのがまあ
リカレント教育という言葉です
これおとなの学びなおしというふうなことかなというふうに思います
実際青山学院大学でも mba だったり
青山アカデメイアというものを開講して世の中にへと社会に出てあたらいている方を
もう1回大学として受け入れて学習をしていただく
そういった取り組みも始まっているかなというふうに思っています
実際こういったリカレント教育というところを通して
今後世の中で必要とされていくような個人になっていただくと言ったところが私自身の
今のテーマかなというふうに考えています
はいこれまで自分自身の過去の経験そして今の世の中の流れから選択していた
キャリアについてお話をさせて頂きましたがじゃあ実際今どんなことをやっているのか
と言うところについて次はお話をさせていただきたいと思います
今ですねえと個人のキャリアだったりスキルというものを
サポートしたいという思いから林間度モチベーショングループにてキャリア
ナビゲーターという仕事をしています
こういったずなんですけれどもこれは人材要件フレームという私たちがよく読んでいる
ずになります
特に上の三つをちょっと見ていただきたいと思います
一番上テクニカルスキルこれは例えば専門の資格専門知識のような業務に直結する
スキルのことを指しています
その下にあるリテラシースキルこれは例えばパソコンのスキルのような業務を下支えし
てくれるスキルのことを言っています
その人にあるポータブルスキルこれはどんな職種
どんな業界に働くにしても通用する人間の根本的なスキルというふうに私たちは言って
います
こういった3つのスキルを開発しながら健食のサポートをしたり
そういった仕事の中で個人個人のキャリア開発というものを今はサポートさせて
いただいています
これまで自分自身入社から半年間働いてきまして
まあ前者で表彰していただく機会があったりですとか
自分の出身である宮城県仙台市を拠点に仕事ができて日々充実しているなというふうに
実感しています
ただやはり大学時代のひえーい
の組織から今会社という利益を追い求める組織に活動の拠点
自分自身の
所属を移したことで日々学び直しを行っている段階かなというふうに感じています
具体的には大学時代のプロジェクトというのは大きな箱を作って
そこに参加をしてくれる学生一人ひとりが自分のキャリアを描いていってほしいという
まあ受動的な思いもあったんですが今は仕事として個人にもっと踏み込んでいかなきゃ
いけないと
そして結果利益も上げなきゃいけないこういった想いと利益のバランスというのは今
自分自身が
学び直しをしている段階かなというふうに思っています
はいここまでですね自分自身の過去の経験そして今のキャリア選択に至るまでお話をさ
せていただきました
例えば教科書を読んだりとか参考書を読むことでキャリアを描く参考にはなると思い
ますがそれだけで自分自身の描きたいキャリアが描けるわけではありません
行動した結果得られる自分にしかない経験だったり
出来事というのが自分のキャリアを形作ってくれるというふうに思っています
そういった意味でも
その経験というのは例えば成功体験でなくても構いません
ついに僕は思っています
僕みたいな一見辛い経験をしたことが後に自分のキャリアを方向付けてくれる大きな
きっかけになることも多いと思っています
また僕がこれ日々感じていることなんですけれども特に学生さんとかは
いろんなことを考えるって
行動に移せなくて自分探しをする方が非常に多いかなと思うんですが
大事なのは自分づくりだと思っています
そういう意味でも皆さんどんどんたくさん行動していただいてそこから得られる自分に
しかない経験
出来事こういったものを通して自分だけ4回掛けないキャリアを描いていてほしいなと
いうふうに思っています
この話を通してですね少しでも皆さんの参考になるような事があれば幸いです
ありがとうございました
[拍手]